this week is an extremely important week  in my life  I'm extremely tough decision listen up  bachelor babes after months about  rageous moments swoon worthy dates and  crazy confrontations crystals has  finally handed out the final rose hey  everyone I'm Liana Galera and the  bachelor finale is what's trending on 80  now so which lucky lady did Prince  farming choose say congratulations to  Whitney it feels so right it feels so  perfect and that's what I want for the  rest my life at the end of Monday  night's bachelor finale the Iowa farmers  sent Becca home and decided to seal the  deal by saying I love you to 29 year old  Whitney Bishop he popped the question  using a beyond gorgeous kneeling  engagement ring and of course she said  yes  are you happy that Chris propose to  Whitney shout out your thoughts to me on  Twitter using that et now hashtag and  for the latest bachelor news keep it  locked to et online